protest is a Malawi seal off the
building of the Electoral Commission
hundreds marched through the streets of
the southern city of Blantyre only a few
managed to get past police barricades a
protest leader says he will only take
the chains off when the Commission's
chairwoman Jane Anza and her staff
resign actually we observed the gates of
neck because Oh what we need is this
personnel in this office should resign
so we don't want them to get inside this
room in the Capitol a long way
people also march towards the offices of
the Electoral Commission it had given
president Peter Mutharika and narrow win
in last year's election for the court
accused the commission of numerous
inconsistencies that included using
correction fluid on ballot sheets
Jane and Sergeant eyes accusations the
results had been altered on the
materials that we sent we indeed did not
include the tippex and even during the
training we thought we told the trainees
that depicts is not allowed but in court
one Election Commission member pointed
the blame at answer the instructions
were given by this year to the CEO
at the time that they see I was getting
sections were not even involved as
Commission I think it just happened
bilaterally Malawi's Constitutional
Court on Wednesday threw out an
application by president Peter math
Erica to suspend the annulled results
the court had given the country just 150
days to order a new election with many
now concern that may not be enough time
to restore confidence in the electoral
process laura buzz manley al jazeera
Alex finds his head of Africa program
but Chatham House he joins us now live
via Skype from London what do you make
of this Alex I mean how anyone could
fail to see that such excessive use of a
well-known correcting fluid on on
balance sheets could could possibly be
linked to problems is beyond me we're
very puzzled by this and saying they
felt that the presidential election
particularly was contentious this
marginal we win for professor were to
recur as president it is strange
therefore that the election monitoring
the observer groups be they
Commonwealth's and African Union all of
them gave the elections a pretty good
bill of health the election results and
again this is another example I think of
the challenges that electoral
observation teams from the outside have
versus the actual process of elections
we saw this as an issue in 2017 in Kenya
where a court ruled that the elections
needed to be run again in 2017 there was
a challenge over the presidential
elections in Liberia for the second
round in the
the court deemed electric go ahead and
so what happened here in Malawi is truly
significant and they'll need to be a
clean election III myself I'm not sure
that the current chairperson of the
Electoral Commission has the confidence
of the Malawian electorate to continue
in that role and so I think she probably
does need to consider her position I was
going to ask you I mean how does Malawi
move forward from here how does it
ensure that that elections in in the
future indeed if this election is itself
rerun how does it ensure their free and
fair well I mean the court has been very
clear that Malawi deserve better that
there were all sorts of anomalies and
inconsistencies and that's not the sort
of quality that they should expect from
their electoral commission and from the
process and so there'll be a rerun of
this presidential election I hope that
there will be a new chairperson of the
Election Commission and they will need
to be close scrutiny of that process
both from domestic observers but also
international ones and I really do have
the electoral observers international
ones reflect on what's happened in
Malawi the International electoral
processes of observation that clearly
and also not necessarily fit the purpose
that they're brought ticking ticking
exercises in many cases and that the
whole methodology needs to be revised
that makes really good to talk to you
many thanks indeed Alex finds there from
Chatham House speaking via Skype from
London